attendez on va attendre c'est twitter
qui va décider sur twitter vous nous
dites est ce qu'on doit sortir gad
elmaleh ou pas parce qu'ici ils vont
vidal en pologne
je suis jaloux pour la boue oui une fois
alors les polonais sont très jolies
blondes pas toutes les filles de l'est
sont très jolies vous aviez conclu non
j'étais jeune
oui jamais très tendre jamais trop igad
là une vanne j'ai failli faire et tu
vois c'est ça quand tu vieillis un peu
c'est qu'avant a pas de filtre j'ai
failli faire une vanne et j'ai eu tout
un comité qui s'est réuni en comité
un comité dans ma tête qu'ils en ont eux
été bien connu sur l'aval de biogaz
ouais mais j'ai envie de la faire quand
même sa défaite le alors c'est alors
vous savez ce qu'on fait c'est quoi vous
allez faire là bas même si vous êtes le
parrain ici vous êtes le taulier de
l'été sur la première c'est vos patrons
ont fait secouer ouais vous sortirez si
elle est mauvaise vous sentirez comme
thierry bon sans renfort la pression
infections
dans le pire c'est quand vous dites vous
sortirez comme thierry moreau et par les
airs comme un prince quelque chose
en fait vous savez ce que le boivent les
filles dans le clip
non ben de l'autre pologne
cooper
attal et on va attendre c'est twitter
qui va décider sur twitter où nous dit
est ce qu'on doit sortir gad elmaleh ou
pas parce qu'ici je pense que dans votre
émission vous devriez créer un truc et
entre tu sors es tu sors pas soirée où
le mec à l'état le mec est puni
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sinon c'est trop radical c'est trop
manichéen c'est trop tout noir ou tout
blanc sur la séquence
c'est comme tu zappes tu mates il
devrait avoir un truc entre les deux
images matus matis mais ça veut dire
temps en temps
un temps en temps je regarde pas je me
laisse aller parce que je crois pas qu'à
zapper mater on va le faire on va le
faire parce que ouais des émissions que
je n'aime pas où je n'irai jamais mais
que j'aime regarder c'est ça mais c'est
l'esma jeu l'asthme à un terrible et
pour l'autre pologne ils sont parlé ils
sont passés de chopin la chopine oui
c'était lacombe yakeba centièmes c'est
la centième sortie
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
pasqua 100 x 200 x
c'est comme ça que tu vas être à 200 je
vais vous dire ce que vous allez faire
vous allez préparer le sketch de coco de
gad elmaleh nom et leur faire devant lui
vous allez nous refaire 30 secondes de
coco ça sera votre garde je peux mettre
la barre un peu plus haut valais moi je
dis plutôt chaud parce qu'à perruque
alors y'a perruque